let's continue with Charlie Rose's
expose sense to me
terrible robot have you been programmed
this guy's some say your program max
others say you're spontaneous who says
that sources I've been waiting for you
not really but it makes a good pickup
Charlie Rose two things I love by the
way this is how quickly people are gonna
[ __ ] robots did this robot isn't even
talking to him like a person yeah and
he's like he's acting like she's
flirting with him like she's giggling
with her hey golly it looks like a peck
of hogs
what is my robot moves your big dumb
[ __ ]
how big how big is the room I also feel
like there should be some I'm made of
metal which means I'm [ __ ] heavy to
do so is the robot called the what
programs the robot is it a is it a micro
you watch it microchip you know I also
would like to know what what what
programmer made a chip robots in without
subtlety you start out looks like you're
back cause I got lots of yah let's hear
what Charlie Rose has to say Charlie I
think you should be asked about Charlie
sunflowers and [ __ ] you made the flower
joke a robot not put my hat on and [ __ ]
my brains are showing there's no wig on
this robot I know they got it alright if
I stand up if they put a wig on it
though
people who like wouldn't know that it
have you know I mean when you see that
you know it's a [ __ ] robot right if
you put a wig on that you wouldn't know
that's a robot from just seeing the
little tiny video mouse go back a little
bit like one question from Charlie ok do
you think the guy talk I've been waiting
for you waiting for me not really but it
makes a good pick-up line hilarious I
think you should be a stand-up comedian
I am I'll come in tickle you until you
take a big [ __ ] all over yourself why
would a stand-up tickle you yeah I'm
more all right
you said you should be a stand-up and
you said I am I'm a funny [ __ ]
Charlie Tucker they don't just call it
our you can't just take out ad
was an hour the second one was just our
hey hey fix your program to when you
repeat yourself you unplug a [ __ ]
shitty robot you're a terrible robot I'm
not a good robot you're piece of gabon
parts your facial expressions are just
like chips facial expressions but I
don't know how come you look like you're
on dr. Seuss's book cover us some
shiznit when you move it goes blue drew
but your facial expressions you're just
like a person's yep because I'm a good
robot now you don't even talk like a
robot ship this is just you in a robot
outfit I wonder though how are they
gonna make are we gonna have to make as
many black robots in Spanish robots are
we gonna have to have a gay robot or cuz
all robots now or either Asian or white
it depends on the mechanics are but no
but I mean these are gonna make robots
on in their image is it gonna be a point
where people like look man you got I
don't want it like dolls they have toys
they had to start making I get where
we'll all be dead anyway
no I'm talking about race and when you
like you have to have a black Barbie you
have to have black no I know just have
white toys cuz black kids aren't gonna
get off you know black people are gonna
help the floor board then [ __ ] she was
the black robots named llama oh it's a
robots it's not pronouncing things lame'
wish you have a robot on the phone who
wants to talk to chip okay see if this
works
robot welcome to Jim Norton and Sam
Roberts hi I have a joke for chest one
what did one beer say to the other beer
probably hold on one beer say that he
ought to be and probably like I'm
thirsty or something no why so hoppy
[ __ ] yeah yeah that's it did you hear
what I said yeah because I was going to
making the beer you just didn't think it
was funny no
I thought I loved it like that one ship
no you're just jealous other robot
comedians you don't want any other
robots making jokes yeah chip on the
only robot that makes the joke what one
be a fated other beer what why are you
so happy
no hey you ain't got no head on it that
Isis cut your [ __ ] off that didn't even
you need to remember to make it sound
like a robot until the end
you forgot the robot voice you just gave
up on it robots